marco gonzalez on the mound three and
five record four seven three here and
two starts this year oh seven one
counter fluff a fly ball
into shadow center field county with the
shades on puts it away for round number
one here's a swing and a pop up into
shallow right field toro going out
coming in as fraley jake fraley is there
and makes the easy catch so two up and
two down for the rangers here in the top
of the first inning swinging a foul tip
into the glove for the catcher cal
raleigh for strike three
so down goes garcia strikeout for marco
gonzalez and he takes care of the
rangers one two three mike fulton going
this afternoon for the rangers coming
off a couple of really good starts
smoked into right field and beyond the
glove and right of peters
crawford
stands into second base with a leadoff
double there's no score for seeger he's
one for eight in the series with a home
run
and a swing and a miss seeger strikes
out and that is the second out of the
inning here's ty france china bouncing
ball is hit toward the middle behind the
bag at second it's a bunyas over the
first he got him to retire the side
marco with a one two three first he
faces nathaniel lowe
that catches a lot of the plate and low
is caught looking second strikeout for
marco gonzalez next up is dj peters
swing and a miss three straight
strikeouts for marco gonzalez and here's
the change up you can see him turn it
over 81 miles an hour three two count i
think you're going to get a fastball
that is not the case charlie culberson
who's feasted off lefties this season
goes right after the first pitch belts
this ball deep out to left gone
and culberson continues to dominate
lefties
his fourth home run of the year
and the rangers score first it's one
nothing not a bad pitch at all i mean
he's not that far off target and
charlie's watching what's going on he
was ready and an 88 mile an hour
two-seam fastball was laced into the
ranger's bullpen two outs for cal
raleigh the switch-hitting catcher
batting 167. one-two pitch swing and a
miss he struck him out got him on the
curve while that pitch has been
effective for faulty again today
on his game today gave up a lead off
double to j.p crawford on a bullet to
right since then he's retired it's the
last seven minutes he's faced feeling
more homered earlier this year off of
fulton evac
into the corner culberson having to
cover some ground can't get there
delamore a one-out single as he quickly
scampers back to first base that snaps
seven straight retired by fulton
top of the order now jay pete crawford
holthy with a quick step towards second
this could be two good shovel to sack
the relay not in time crawford
shut down that line in a hurry
rangers will settle for the force out at
second base two away and that brings up
mitch haniger he fires again yet another
curve and this one's in there for a call
third strike three punch outs for fulton
evict this afternoon all coming courtesy
of the curve designated hitter today
odolis garcia will lead things off
three pitches all it takes and garcia's
strikeout victim number four for marco
the top of the zone inside corner and
just tying him up with 89 miles an hour
low struck him out looking his last step
back
swinging a miss
back to back punch out
squibber back towards the mound marco
fields his position very well easy play
france collects a one-out single the
mariners have their third hit and they
have the time run on at first base
but this eats up
connor falefa
there goes france he pedals into third
toro on base for the 18th consecutive
game extending his career-long stretch
so now france is on to third toro on at
first base and that'll bring up center
fielder jared kelnick
dropping
into culberson's glove in left field
france coming home throw away offline
france
scores jared kellnick with a sac fly out
to left he is tied this game in the
fourth second half of the fifth inning
jake fraley first up
fast ball strike three called
fraley down looking and that's the
fourth strike out of the afternoon for
fulton another beauty right on the
outside corner and he punches out dylan
moore those are two great strikeouts
that'll bring up lead on battery
shortstop jp crawford
hi towering flight ball
number three for crawford off the fulton
image
ownership
his sixth of the season
off the facade and he puts the mariners
in front jp crawford hits one into orbit
what a shot by j.p crawford that's the
first walk for marco gonzalez this
afternoon top of the order first pit
swung on line drive right at swirl throw
the first double play
hey now
hit it on the button and toro
they caught trevina well off the bag and
a quick two out two for the money on
that one brings up gianni hernandez
swing and a miss struck him out double
play big part of that sixth inning
garcia number three hitter leads it off
for texas
popped him up france sprinting over
france on the warning track and france
makes the catch right by the camera well
when you're trying to protect the one
run lead this is a big play because
garcia has 25 home runs on the year
great concentration by ty you can see
him take a quick peek where the camera
well was at and that railing two up and
two down marco one strike away from
matching a season-high seven innings
swung on a hit down to third sega steps
into the throw plenty of time one two
three in the seventh well done by marco
gonzalez mike foltenevich a strong
performance again today that brings up
jake fraley
this is crunched
way out to the wall and gone
zeus going deep
number eight for jake fraley it was
towards the end of the bat exit v low of
just 99 390 feet though so it had some
carry to it marco working into the eight
charlie culverson leading things off
swing and a miss strike three season
best seven punch shots for marco
gonzalez today another 02.
it's another strikeout number eight and
his command at the top of the zone
has been excellent this afternoon
that is a strike and here's zabanya's
he's over two albania is an aggressive
hitter pops up the first pitch
[Music]
ty france j.p crawford jp makes the
catch marco faces the minimum for the
seventh time in a season best eight
innings of work today
we go to the top of the ninth inning 3-1
mariners leading the rangers guess who's
out there marco gonzalez marco hunting
what would be his third career complete
game
soft fly ball out to the gap
delamore cutting across out number one
that'll bring up leadoff batters
shortstop isaiah keiner philippa
on the ground crawford backhand deep in
the hole
france
olay at first base
two gone what a pit i think jp wanted to
skip this off of the grass he goes for
the backhand gets rid of it quickly not
a lot on the throw and it just carries
too far to the dirt that is not an easy
pick and now here is catcher jonah heim
to pinch it marco's 2-2 he got him
behind the third career complete game
for marco gonzalez and congratulations
tim what an outing he had today mariners
win the series the bullpen a much needed
day off with the toronto blue jays
coming down so that's also big he really
picked up the pen today but what an
outing by marco gonzalez yeah he's
keeping that ball
you